-Welcome. Welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, the weather
right now is crazy.
A state of emergency has been
declared here in New York
as a massive nor'easter slams
the East Coast with heavy rain,
flooding, and intense winds.
Yep, we're in
a state of emergency,
or as Facebook calls it,
"Tuesday."
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, it's gross out there.
Right now, the entire East Coast
smells like damp mask.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, we're dealing with
that intense wind where
your mask blows off your face
and lands onto someone else's.
[ Laughter ]
Wait, I'm vaxxed.
Are you vaxxed?
[ Laughter ]
Here in New York City,
the streets were so flooded,
all the shrimp at Bubba Gump
made a break for the Hudson.
[ Laughter ]
Let's go, boys! Yeah.
That's right. Already,
thousands have lost power,
making it the one time
people actually turned on
their iPhone flashlights
on purpose.
It's like,
"Oh, that's what it's for."
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to some news.
Of course, everyone's been
talking about Facebook lately,
and Mark Zuckerberg just
announced that he's "retooling"
the social-media platform
towards young adults
and away from older users.
Honestly, just make it
a little harder to sign in
and you'll never see
an old person on Facebook again.
[ Laughter ]
That's all you got to do.
[ Applause ]
"How many stop signs?
Scan my face?"
My aunt's gonna
have a lot of free time.
She can't use Facebook
to write "love this"
under every inspirational quote.
[ Laughter ]
You're really inspired today.
Wow.
Meanwhile, today executives from
TikTok and Snapchat testified
before a Senate panel
for the first time.
Usually, the only tick-tock
on Capitol Hill
is coming from
a senator's pacemaker.
[ Laughter ]
"It's not ticking anymore.
You better --"
[ Laughter ]
Give it a little --
There, now it's working again.
Yeah, it was hours of
tech executives
trying to explain their apps
to senators.
Experts are calling it a preview
of your family at Thanksgiving.
[ Laughter ]
"So how do I get
to the Snapchat?"
[ Laughter ]
Yep, senators believe social
media is corrupting our teens,
and they might be
on to something,
because a bunch of 15-year-olds
barged in
for a "lick a senator"
challenge.
[ Laughter ]
"Take his flag pin
then throw bologna at him."
[ Laughter ]
That's a challenge.
-That's a challenge.
-Yeah, of course.
-Wet mask.
-Yeah. That's right.
A TikTok executive appeared
before Senate.
It was pretty interesting.
Here's what happened
when they asked why TikTok
has so much misinformation
on its platform.
♪ -Out to play ball
so we could ruin them ♪
♪ Mama said that it was okay ♪
♪ Mama said that
it was quite alright ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
Some more news from Washington.
President Biden
is still negotiating
his new spending bill with
Congress and hopes to have
a deal by the end of this week.
Biden's bill
started at $3.5 trillion
and now it's down
to about $2 trillion.
Right now he's like a guy
at the airport taking stuff
out of his bag
to get it under 50 pounds.
He's like, "I don't think
I need shirts, right?
How much are we going to
wear shirts, right?"
[ Laughter ]
"I guess I could wear
my ski boots on the plane."
[ Laughter ]
The deal is getting held up
'cause senators Joe Manchin
and Kyrsten Sinema
keep adding stipulations.
It's getting nuts.
Right now they won't
sign the bill
until Kyrie Irving
is allowed to play for the Nets.
[ Laughter ]
Some business news -- Hertz just
announced that it's buying
100,000 Teslas for its fleet of
rental cars.
Yep. Then to give Hertz a taste
of their own medicine,
Tesla said, "Sorry, we don't
have any Teslas right now.
Is a Kia Rio okay?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you.
"That's all we have. Sorry.
And with this rental,
you keep this car."
[ Laughter ]
"It's your problem --
I mean, your car now."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I read about a man
in Georgia who's facing
federal charges
after he spent over $57,000
in COVID relief funds
on a single Pokemon card.
[ Laughter ]
Wow. His wife would be
so embarrassed if she existed.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's gonna be rough
when he gets to prison
and he explains he's there
because he loves Squirtle.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh! Oh, oh!
-Hey, guys, get this.
I heard about a guy who bought
a Six Flags annual pass.
How about this deal?
You get the Six Flags
annual pass, right?
It allows you to get
unlimited food for 150 bucks.
He's eaten nearly all of his
meals at Six Flags ever since.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, all the money
he saved is now going to doctors
to get his cholesterol
down from 1,000.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a man in Lithuania
broke a world record
by sitting up to his neck
in a container of ice
for three hours.
[ Audience oohs ]
Then he stood up
and broke the record
for most disappointed
girlfriend.